LEON NICHOLLS: Hi, my
name is Leon Nicholls.
I'm a Developer Advocate
for Google Cast.
I'm here to tell you about the
Google Cast SDK for Android.
The Google Cast SDK
supports Android, iOS,
and desktop Chrome platforms.
Apps developed for
these platforms can all
interact with any Google Cast
device, such as Chromecast.
The Google Cast
sender application
refers to an app running on
a mobile device or laptop,
and the receiver application
refers to an HTML application
running on Chromecast or other
Google Cast receiver devices.
The release of the
Google Cast SDK
is the public API for
developers of Cast applications.
From now on, developers
are in control
of releasing the Cast apps by
using the new Google Cast SDK
developer console.
The Google Cast SDK is now a
part of Android's Google Play
services, and will be
shared across all Cast apps.
Let's take a look at the typical
life cycle of a Cast sender
app.
When the sender app is
launched, Cast devices
need to be discovered
on the local network.
Once the user selects a
device, the sender app
will connect to that device
and launch the receiver app.
The sender app then
creates a message channel
to the receiver app to
send and receive messages.
The user can also
disconnect from that device.
The first step in
supporting Cast in an app
is to add the Cast button.
There are three choices-- the
MediaRouter ActionBar provider,
the MediaRouter button,
or a custom button.
We recommend the provider since
that's the easiest integration.
The Cast button has to be added
to the menu for the ActionBar,
or to the activity
layout resource file.
The advantage to create a
MediaRouter selector, which
will fall to devices
to discover only
Cast devices that
can run your app.
The selector is attached
to the Cast button
when the activity starts.
Here is an example
of how easy it
is to add a Cast
button to the ActionBar
[? compat ?] using the
MediaRouter ActionBar provider
in your menu XML.
Other ways of integrating
the Cast button
is documented by the
MediaRouter support library.
The sender app also has to
tell the MediaRouter to start
discovery of Cast
devices by adding
a callback when the
activity starts.
The app will be informed
by the MediaRouter
when the user has selected
a device from the Cast menu.
As a best practice,
remove the callback
when discovery is
no longer needed,
to conserve battery usage.
Here's an example of how to add
a callback to the MediaRouter
to start device discovery.
The device the user
has selected is
extracted from
the callback data.
Now that the sender
app knows which
Cast device the
user has selected,
launching the receiver
app involves a few steps.
The sender app needs to connect
to Google Play Services using
the GoogleAPIClient Cast.
Then the app uses
the Cast.CastAPI
Cast to launch the receiver
app using the app ID obtained
from the Developer Console.
Once the receiver
app has launched,
the sender can create a media
message channel or a custom
message channel to the receiver.
The app has to handle
various callbacks
about the application
and the channel status.
Here's an example of how
to launch the receiver
app once the sender app has
connected to Google Play
services.
The result callback is
invoked with the launch status
and the application metadata.
Note the same asynchronous
callback model
is used throughout the
life cycle of a Cast app.
To play media on the
receiver, the sender app
has to create a
MediaInfo instance
with the URL of
the media stream.
The RemoteMediaPlayer
Cast is then
used to load that media
stream on the receiver.
The sender app then accepts
commands such as play and pause
using the RemoteMediaPlayer.
The sender app has to handle
callbacks about the media
status during playback.
Finally, let's take
a look at an example
of how to create a MediaInfo
instance for a video stream.
The video stream is loaded
on the receiver using
the RemoteMediaPlayer instance.
The ResultCallback is invoked
with the load command status.
You can get more details
about the Google Cast SDK
at developers.google.com/cast.
It's also important to take
a look at the Cast Design
Checklist, which has design
implications for your app.
We've also opened
source sample Cast apps
that you can use as a reference.
If you have any
developer questions,
post those on Stack Overflow.
Join our Google Cast Developers
Community on Google+.
Happy Casting.